did you know that Whitebeard used to
look like this or that big mouth went
from this happy little child to eating
her friends alive or that Frankie almost
joined Goldie Rogers crew as a kid well
today we're gonna look at every single
backstory in one piece starting with the
oldest character that we know of which
is this elephant well you see this is
actually a highly intelligent creature
the size of four Mount Everest that was
already alive during the void century
and that was a companion of the
legendary character called Joy boy the
elephant's name is zunisha and what we
know for a fact is that it committed
such a terrible crime that as a
punishment it has been ordered to walk
the oceans for over 800 years waiting
for the return of Joy boy not only that
but during this extremely long time a
race of human-like animals called the
Minx ended up building an entire country
on its back and speaking of super old
characters we also can't wait to learn
more about other mysterious people from
the void Century like Joy boy who
probably used to have Luffy's legendary
devil fruit or Odin's wife Toki who time
traveled to the future or the secret
king of the world emu who seems to have
been ruling from the shadows for all
this time in addition characters like
the gurusai may also well be from the
same time period as well so hopefully
Oda has a giant backstory prepared for
us to explain the void century and all
of the people who lived and fought
during these last 100 years and speaking
of giant-sized backstories were moving
on to these two giants who are some of
the oldest characters in one piece
Dorian bragi are a crazy 160 years old
both of them grew up on the island of
giants called elbaf and later formed
their own pirate crew of giant Warriors
however at some point they started a
really Petty fight over who had hunted
the larger animal and so when Luffy and
the crew meet them they've actually been
dueling for exactly 100 years which
actually ended up creating a lot of
trouble for the rest of their crew
because without their captains the two
Giants oimo and Kashi were later
blackmailed by the world government into
working for them with the government
pretending that they had captured their
friends and this guy here called
hydrogen he ended up as a gladiator
fighting for the entertainment of others
inside the massive Arena on dressrosa
but even bigger and older than these
Giants though was horse while he lived
500 years ago this ancient giant was 159
years old at the time of his death
allegedly he was a terrible villain
called the consonant polar and after
ravaging lands across the world he froze
to death in the icy Northern continent
waiting for the day that maurya would
dig him up and revive him as a zombie
however oars also had a descendant
called little ores Jr now little Oz Jr
was an ally of Whitebeard and helped
during the marineford war to free Ace
because Ace had once gifted him a straw
hat from the land of wano however the
first Straw Hat they were actually going
to talk about today is the oldest one
this talking singing skeleton has one of
the most tragic backstories in all of
One Piece his crew the Rumba Pirates
were friends with A young whale named
laboon little laboon loved to hear
Brooke's music but when the crew entered
the grand line they had to leave laboon
behind promising that they'd meet back
again one day however getting stuck in
the Florian triangle which is basically
the one piece version of the infamous
Bermuda Triangle his entire crew slowly
died of starvation however thanks to his
yomiyominomi Brooke was revived after
death and kept living on as a skeleton
he was cursed continue wandering The
Mists of the Florian triangle until he
joined the straw hat Pirates however
thankfully even death couldn't get rid
of that sweet sweet afro and up next is
the former Fleet admiral of the Marines
sengoku while he's now carefree and
living his best life in retirement we
know from this childhood drawing that
Oda made that he was actually very
disciplined because as a child we can
see him practicing his calligraphy here
preparing him for a very long career of
filing paperwork for Garth because on
the other hand this childhood drawing of
Monkey D GARP gives a very different
impression GARP is Luffy's grandfather
and we can definitely see the
resemblance to Luffy because GARP
absolutely looks more like a pirate as a
kid than a marine this wild child would
grow up to be the hero of the Marines he
took down terrible criminals like Don
Xin Zhao whose head he punched so hard
it went from being pointy to round now
Don Ching Zhao would never forgive him
for ruining his perfectly spiky heads
and would try to carry out the grudge
against garb's grandson Luffy not only
that but Garb also had a friendly
rivalry with the pirate king Goldie
Roger this pair of Frenemies teamed up
at God Valley to fight the Rocks Pirates
now we don't know anything about his
past or where he came from all we know
is that Roxy's back has collected a crew
of some of the most powerful pirates in
the world legendary characters like
whitebeard's big mom kaido Shiki or
Stussy with this crew of absolute
monsters Rock's ultimate goal was to
destroy the celestial dragons and become
the king of the world but in the end was
defeated by Roger and GARP together and
after the incident had got Valley GARP
became known as the hero of the Marines
and Raja would become pirate king so
let's talk about him for a second here
some things that we know from Rogers
past are that he originally owned Luffy
straw hat before passing it on to Shanks
who then in turn pass it on to Luffy but
most importantly along with kozuki Odin
and the rest of his crew he was the
first person to ever reach the final
Island and find the one piece whatever
this treasure was it must have been
really funny because Roger burst out
laughing when he found it and he decided
to name the hidden island laughtail for
some reason he had arrived to the
treasure too early in his own words and
unfortunately he also had contracted a
deadly disease and so he did everything
in his power so that the right person
would be able to find the island once
again after that Roger turned himself
into the world government and announced
the existence of the one piece to the
world starting the grand pirate era as
people scrambled to find his treasure
however before he died Roger did one
more thing he had fathered a son with a
woman named Portugues D Rouge in secret
and before his execution he had asked
Garb to adopt this son even though Roger
was a pirate and Garb was a marine he
trusted his longtime rival more than
anyone to see to it that his son had a
chance to live his life despite being
related to the most wanted criminal and
GARP actually agreed to adopt that son
who would go by the name of Ace and was
raised as Luffy's brother but we'll get
to that in just a bit first we have to
go back a little bit though because we
just skipped over some massive names
right here let's talk about the
remaining members of The Rock's pirate
crew three of whom would even go on to
become Emperors of the sea I mean just
look at this picture of Whitebeard as a
kid can you believe that this guy grew
up to become the world's strongest man
not to mention that he used to have a
serious nice head of hair it does seem
like he never did have an actual beard
though now why they grew up on this
island that was too poor to pay the
insanely high taxes to the world
government and therefore had to defend
itself from Pirates and Bandits on its
own this turned Whitebeard into one of
the most powerful fighters in all of One
Piece and his crewmate Charlotte linlin
was the sweet sweet little girl here who
didn't know her own strength her parents
had abandoned her on elbaf where her
hunger pains led to her absolutely
bodying some Giants little hydrogen for
example who we mentioned earlier was
even there as a kid as well fortunately
though mother caramel was here to raise
linlin inside her orphanage
unfortunately though mother caramel was
also a scam artist who sold orphans to
the world governments double unfortunate
at the world's worst birthday party big
mom ate all of her friends and mother
caramel alive along with her devil fruit
gaining her sold Soul Powers after that
big mom built her food-related Empire
attracting numerous husbands along the
way kaido was another rocks pirate with
a seriously messed up childhood ever
since he was a kid he was used as a
human weapon due to his immense strength
and then after a period as a government
test subject he found his way to the
Rocks Pirates where big mom gave him his
Dragon devil fruit and while he was a
government test subject he also broke
out a fellow prisoner Arbor who he then
renamed into King and King is the last
known member of the lunarian race a
mysterious race with black wings dark
skin light hair and fire related powers
in fact King is the one that teaches
kaido about the myths surrounding Joy
boy which then leads kaido to want to up
his base of operation inside juano and
since the two were being experimented on
in Punk Hazard this is likely where
kaido first encountered queen as well
since Queen previously worked with the
other scientists of maths this is a
research group created by Dr vegapung
another notable kaido crewmate is who's
who this member of the flying six used
to be a cp9 agent until shank stole the
go-mobileumi that he was responsible for
guarding after this who's who was
imprisoned by the government but was
eventually freed and became a
subordinate of kaido hiding his true
identity and later on kaido would
encounter one of his fiercest enemies
with kozuki Odin and wano and have the
fight of his life we already mentioned
Odin a little bit earlier since he
sailed together with Roger to love tail
but we have got to take a minute to talk
about this Giga chat's true Past after
growing up as a troublemaker Odin was
named the Daniel of the Lawless land of
kuri by his father the Shogun of the
wano country this is where he gathered
his nine retainers the nine rats
scabbards kinemon benjiro kalamatsu
Ashura doji me komamushi inwarashi hiku
Daiso and kanjaro alongside with them
though fought others as well like to
bewitching ninja shinobu however after a
chance meeting with Whitebeard Odin went
to sea to explore the world outside of
juano and while they were sailing he met
his wife Toki a time traveler from the
void century and they had their two
children momonosuke and hiori later
after swapping Crews from Whitebeard to
Roger he then went to love tale and then
finally returned to wano with the goal
of opening its borders unfortunately in
the time that he'd been gone Orochi had
pulled a power play with the backing of
kaido to gain control over wano Orochi
was part of the kudozumi clan who sought
to take revenge on the kozuki clan for
past conflicts he even went as far as
installing kanjudo another secret
kurozumi among Odin's retainers finally
though after a climactic battle kaido
finally executed Odin while his
retainers fled to the Future using
toki's powers this ended up sealing a
rochi's position as the Shogun of wano
and it led to terrible times on wano for
the common people like for example Tama
however during Luffy's brother Asus time
on wano he met Tama and gave her hope
for the future and while he was there
ACE also met Yamato kaido's son who was
inspired to adopt the name of Odin after
seeing his bravery during his execution
however despite being extremely
supportive of Yamato's Newfound identity
kaido was otherwise a terrible Father
Figure locking her in explosive
handcuffs and confining her to
onigashima for her entire life so now we
can move from wano to eckhit Island
where we finally met The Eccentric
scientist Dr vegapan this genius was
inspired to uncover and decipher the
secret knowledge lost to the world after
his friend and colleague Professor
Clover was killed at O'Hara and as the
leader and founder of the science group
mads he also used to work with other
crazy scientists such as Vince milk
judge Caesar Clown and queen of course
while vegapunk secretly works with the
Revolutionary Army he keeps up
appearances by making Tech technology
for the world governments and so let's
talk about the Marine Admirals now we
don't know much yet about the past of
the original Three Admirals but Oda has
drawn all three of them as children
forcelino appears to have always just
been as carefree as he is now sakazuki
looks like he had a very rough childhood
I'm willing to bet that his absolute
hatred of pirates was inspired from a
very young age and kuzan appears to have
been extremely disgruntled and possibly
a victim of childhood alcoholism
seriously why is baby aokiji carrying
that Bob around as for our other
Admirals we don't actually quite know
much about them yet we do know that
fujitora blinded himself after seeing
terrible atrocities in the world and
we're super curious about what those
atrocities were and aramaki on the other
hand is still a complete mystery we know
nothing about him and another even more
mysterious character indeed one of the
most mysterious in the whole series is
Luffy's father Dragon the most wanted
man in the world and leader of the
revolutionaries recently in Dr
vegapung's flashback we learned that the
destruction of Ohara is what inspired
Dragon to join together with Emporio
ivankov and Bartholomew Kuma to form the
Revolutionary Army however it's still to
be seen what traumatic event caused
dragons to become an absentee father
because it seems to be all too common in
the one piece world that just throwing
kids in the jungle is the equivalent of
a daycare of course having the parent
present isn't always a good thing though
like for big mom's many many traumatized
children at age 50 petospero is the
eldest son of big mom followed by the
triplets katakuri oven and daifuku now
we don't have full backstories on all of
the Charlotte family because the most
detail we get is from katakuri brelay
and pudding for example we know that
katakuri's other siblings would make fun
of his huge donut-eating mouth calling
him a pelican eel while they went with
this obscure deep sea creature instead
of just calling him a pelican is a
little bit of a mystery though after
could a curry beat them up in response
his brothers took their Revenge out on
relay scarring her face afterwards
katakuri began covering up his mouth in
his mind he was doing it to protect his
siblings as well as cultivating a
serious image putting on the other hand
spent her entire childhood being
ridiculed for her third eye even being
called hideous by her own mother so
really the Charlotte's aren't what you
would exactly call a loving and
supporting family let's now move on to
the shitibukaido first gekkomoria Moria
was once an idealistic young pirate with
his sight set on Rising to the top of
the one piece World however after
challenging the emperor kaido his entire
crew was mercilessly killed and him
losing his entire crew is what would
Inspire him to use a zombie army in the
future because he can't lose his crew
and relive the pain if they're already
dead to replace his old Crew He gathered
followers like Hawk back a skilled
surgeon with a twisted reputation
because Hawk back helped maurya Stitch
his zombie army together include during
cindery who was a famous stage actress
in life that was resurrected as a Zombie
by The Mad Scientist Absalom another
crew member had his face partially
spliced with a lion to better resemble
the Predator that he is as we can see
from this drawing though perona has
pretty much been a goth girl since day
one it's not just a phase with her
Bartholomew Kuma another warlord win
countered on Thriller Barrack was known
as a tyrant and served as the ruler of
the sorbet Kingdom he's also jewelry
Bonnie's father and he was also a
prominent founding member of the
Revolutionary Army but was converted by
Dr Mega Punk into a cyborg in service of
the world government Kuma was also used
as the basis for the pacifista robots as
well and we already got a glimpse that
Kuma might have the single most
traumatic past in the entire story of
One Piece now crocodile was the very
first warlord that Luffy ever defeated
we can't tell a whole lot about
crocodile's past but we do know that he
has a grudge against Whitebeard in
addition we also know that he has a deep
dark secret that only Emporio ivankovnos
and while working with Nico Robin his
organization Baroque Works decided to
try and steal the Throne of alabaster
while crocodile secretly saw the ancient
weapon pluton and it should be noted
that crocodile as a child is very gender
ambiguous but do with that information
what he wants crocodile plotted against
nifatadi Cobra the Beloved ruler of the
desert island Alabaster his daughter
princess Vivi is even an honorary
strawhead member after their travels
together and is one of the original 40
kingdoms that founded the world
government the nifataris regularly
attempt the reverie as a child there
Vivi encountered Walpole the monarch of
the drunk Kingdom who showed his true
colors by slapping her while she was
still a child and while in Alabaster
Vivi also grew up as a close friend of
khoza who would eventually lead the
rebel Army fueled by crocodiles lice
into seats as children Vivi joined Koza
Suna Suna club and later these Brave
kids once actually saved vivi's life
from kidnappers jimbei the Knight of the
sea and Curran's draw had Pirates got
his start on the Sun Pirates under a
captain called Fisher tiger Fisher tiger
was once enslaved by the celestial
dragons after his Escape he
single-handedly scaled the red line back
to marijua and released the rest of the
slaves there in a legendary one-man
assault against the world government
Capital later the sun Pirates branded
themselves with the symbol of the sun to
cover up the celestial dragons brand
that they were marked with as slaves in
fact all members of the crew received a
sun brand so that people couldn't
differentiate who was a former slave and
who was not the sun symbol itself of
course being related to the Sango Nika
who we now know was worshiped by slaves
as a god of Liberation and the sun
Pirates also escorted a former slave who
would then grow up to be the
Revolutionary koala back home as well
however they were attacked by a squad of
Marines and Fisher tiger was shot
eventually Fisher tiger died needing a
blood transfusion however due to his
hatred of humans he couldn't let himself
receive blood from a human and passed
away afterwards jinbei and arlong fought
for leadership of the sun pirates in the
end jimbei gained control of the crew
eventually becoming a warlord in order
to better the terms between the
government and Fishman Islands arlong
meanwhile formed his own arlang pirate
crew and moved to the east blue where he
constructed our Long Park now not a lot
is known about Dracula mihawk's past
either we know that he was a long time
rival and friend of Shanks at least
until Shanks lost his arm we also know
that before becoming a warlord he was
known as The Marine Hunter just pretty
badass another former warlord donkey
Flamingo is a Celestial Dragon however
after his father left their position as
a Celestial Dragon and they left the
holy land they moved to the Sea only to
be met with hatred and prosecution by
the people there and So eventually
doflamingo killed his own father but it
was too late to regain his position in
marijuana and so after being taken in by
treble the younger Flamingo then began
on his path to becoming an Infamous and
cruel pirate and eventually he claimed
the kingdom of dressrosa the donkey
karts family's original ancestral home
as his own once again before
doflamingo's Invasion dress Rosa was a
peaceful Kingdom led by the king Riku
Kiros a legendary gladiator who became
captain of the royal guard even married
King riku's daughter and the two had
their own daughter together named
princess Rebecca the family lived
happily until doflamingo used his string
powers to manipulate Riku causing him to
cut down his own citizens now Kudos made
a stand against the donkey shot Pirates
but one of doflamingo's subordinates
named sugar used her devil fruit power
to turn Kiros into a toy soldier and a
side effect of this power was that
everyone forgot that Kiros had ever
existed however the toy soldier version
of kuros still helped raise Rebecca
teaching her how to defend herself as
Riku and Rebecca were both forced to
compete in resrosa's colosseum for their
own Survival and the Don Quixote
family's entertainment and another set
of oda's drawings from the SBS sections
of the manga treat us to some of the Don
quixot family members as children's as
well we can see that treble has always
been disgusting and also see a
Gladius and Monet however of course the
donkey shot family member with the most
fleshed out backstory is none other than
Senor paint Senor Ping's backstory came
seemingly out of nowhere but managed to
tuck on fans heart strength and is
considered among the best in the series
long ago Senor pink fell in love with a
woman named Russian together they even
had a child named Jim lit but all along
Russian didn't know that her husband was
part of a crime family and a pirate
unfortunately gimlet passed away as an
infant from illness and afterwards
Russian learned the truth behind Sandra
pink she ran away but was caught in a
landslide causing her to fall into a
vegetative state it's on your pink would
visit her every single in the hospital
and one day would put on their baby's
head while expressing grief over their
son and his wife actually reacted by
smiling despite being in a coma which
led to Senor pink dressing more and more
like a baby to get a reaction from his
beloved wife and so Senor pink still
dresses as a baby to this day it's just
a hard-boiled thing to do but Waldo
Flamingo was a Celestial Dragon our next
chichibukai was a victim of the
Celestial Dragon Boa Hancock the Empress
of Amazon Lily was enslaved by the
celestial dragons as a child along with
her two sisters however she was then
later set free during Fisher Tiger's
attack on marijua Hancock has also known
Silva Israeli for a long time given that
Rayleigh spell shaky was the former
Empress of Amazon lily as well and later
on she became a warlord in order to
protect Amazon Lily from the world
government Blackbeard or Marshall D
teach also had a terrible childhood as
we can tell from this childhood drawing
from Oda here we can see him crying
under a crescent moon as a young boy he
was taken in by Whitebeard and people
quickly noticed his peculiar traits such
as the fact that he never sleeps now we
still have to learn a lot about his past
but since his ship's name was the saber
of zebek it's clear that he was somehow
inspired by or related to Roxy's back
and his crewmates are all also notorious
in their own rights we don't know much
about the past of Jesus Burgess doc Q or
van auger but Lafitte was a former
police officer talk about a crooked cop
and Blackbeard's other crewmates were
all recruited from imple down which
means that characters like Katarina
Devon Vasco shot San Juan wolf and avalo
Pizarro all have lengthy criminal
records Shiri who on the other hand
wasn't just a prison of imple down he
was a former head Jailer who was so
cruel to the inmates that they had to
imprison him as well as a child when the
Whitebeard and Roger Pirates met
Blackbeard also met a young Shanks now
Shanks was found by Roger in a Treasure
Chest at God Valley and was then adopted
by the crew as a result Shanks became a
cabin boy along with buggy both of whom
would grow up to become yonko and while
aboard Roger's ship buggy accidentally
consumed The Chop Chop fruit gaining his
devil fruit Powers before Roger's
execution Shanks inherited his captain
straw hats and one day he would give the
straw hat to Luffy and sometime after
Roger's death Shanks would steal the
gomogomonomi from the Marines which
Luffy would then later eat and now we
move back to ancient history for the so
far oldest flashback chronologically in
the series so far where we learn about
kalgara and Mont Blanc Nolan montbla
Noland also known as Nolan the liar was
a famous explorer he befriended the
dwarves of green but also traveled
to Jaya where he met the shandians and
saw the City of Gold while he was there
he befriended the shandyan warrior
kalgaro he promised to return one day
but by the time that he had returned
shandora had already been sent up to Sky
Pia by the knock-up stream and Noland
was remembered by history as a great
liar in the present-day story skypeia
would be conquered by Eno strangely NL
and his crewmates were not from skypier
but another sky island called burka
after he gained his lightning powers he
destroyed burka without his second
thought and eventually wound up on
skypia and declared himself a Gothic Mad
Monk urush another Sky Islander is one
of the supernovas we don't know much
about his backstory yet but we do have
this drawing of him where he was
sporting the traditional skypian
hairstyle we can only hope that when he
returns in the series he will bring this
look back at some point because looking
good Capone beige was known as a famous
mafioso back in the West Blue before
entering the grand line and according to
this picture he loved playing with
blocks as a kid building the castle that
he would eventually become with his
devil fruit x-rayed on the other hand
had quite different Ambitions he didn't
want to become a pirate instead he
dreamed of becoming a Marine a dream
that would come true while he grew up to
be a member of sword the secret Marine
organization basil Hawkins God pressed
his soul got his practice as a tarot
card reader very early on as well it
seems and scratch when a poo got in
plenty of piano lessons before his teeth
became an actual keyboard taking a
detour from the supernovas though we
have our very own cyborg Frankie he was
born with the name Kari flam which
explains why he'd want to undergo change
to the much much cooler sounding of
Frankie he was abandoned by his pirate
parents and grew up on the island of
shipwright's water 7. as a young
inventor Frankie constructed numerous
battleships he named battle Frankies he
and the future mayor Iceberg were raised
by the legendary shipwright Tom who
constructed gold D Rogers ship the oral
Jackson in fact during Roger and Odin's
Voyage they visited Tom and Odin even
invited a young Frankie to join their
crew however Frankie refused because he
hated pirates on account of having been
abandoned by Pirates another parental
figure to Frankie was kokoro a secret
mermaid and secretary to Tom later in
his life Tom was then put on trial for
constructing the oral Jackson to avoid
execution he agreed to build the sea
train for the government however after
construction was completed in a plot to
acquire the blueprints to the ancient
weapon pluton zp9 spandem used Frankie's
battleships to Stage an attack on water
7. in the end Tom received the blame for
the attack and was sentenced to death in
an effort to stop cp9 Frankie hits
Phantom's face with a rifle permanently
scarring him and he also stood in the
way of the sea train in an effort to
stop it from taking tomsu and his Lobby
which horribly wounded Frankie however
in a stroke of Real Genius Frankie was
able to rebuild himself into the cyborg
that we know and love today speaking of
spandom though he started in the family
Espionage business early following in
the footsteps of his father's band line
he and the rest of the zp9 members from
The anislobby Arc are also pictured here
as kids confusingly spandom's pictured
here with a young elephant which is
strange because Funk freed was a sword
that ate an elephant fruit we can only
guess that he received
sword at a very young age then I guess
the various ep9 members Jabra kumadori
Bruno fukoro Khalifa Kaku and Luchi were
all trained as Government spies and
assassins from childhood the one that we
know the most about of course is Rob
Lucci himself apparently he has known
his pigeon hathorui since he was a very
young boy which begs the question how
long do pigeons actually live in the one
piece World Luchi was made famous in an
operation he conducted at age 13 where
he mercilessly killed 500 soldiers that
were taken hostage along with the
Pirates Who were holding them this
proved his Savage brand of dark Justice
to the world government and made him one
of their deadliest assets Luchi is a fan
favorite villain and Cody Jones is Not
in case you forgot hody Jones was the
captain of the new Fishman Pirates Who
served as the main antagonist of the
Fishman island arc he once served as a
soldier in King Neptune's army during
Queen and otohima's Reign Queen orohime
was a ruler who promoted peace between
the races despite the prosecution
fishmen had to face at the hands of
humans her daughter shirahoshi was
revealed to be Poseidon a member of the
Fishman royal family with the power to
command the Sea King sander decken one
of hody Jones's allies touched hirohoshi
as a child using his markmok fruit power
which allows him to throw objects and
weapons at her from anywhere which
forced a young princess to live most of
her life in isolation within ryokugo
kringdom's Castle which forced her to
live most of her life in isolation
within ryugu Kingdom's Castle protected
from random flying axes which is kind of
gruesome now due to his hatred of humans
hody Jones assassinated Queen orohime to
create conflict between the races
inspired by his Idol arlong he founded
the new Fishman pirates with the goal of
taking over Fishman Island and
eventually Waging War against humans on
the surface using the power of the
energy steroids from the Tama Tobacco
Box treasure he and his crewmates gained
incredible powers that allowed them to
almost take over Fishman Island itself
they just didn't count on those meddling
straw hats showing up in the end in our
next strawhead crew member is Nico Robin
who liked the rest of her crewmates has
an extremely tragic backstory Robin grew
up on O'Hara the island of Scholars
Professor Clover and the other
researchers had uncovered the mysteries
of the Void Century the ancient Kingdom
and The Language written on the pony
glyphs unbreakable blocks spread around
the world that carry forgotten
historical knowledge one day a giant
Marine named Jaguar de Saul washed
ashore and befriended Robin he warned
her that the Marines were coming to
attack O'Hara to destroy and cover up
the knowledge that the scholars had
uncovered so far oh yeah and one
important detail is that Robin also grew
up without parents very lonely on that
island however after Saul's warning
Robin's mother Nicole alvia also
returned to ahora but her professor
Clover and all the other residents of
the island were killed by the Marines
Admiral aokiji actually allowed Robin to
escape making her the sole survive of
the island at least that's what we
thought and in order to make a living
she ended up joining with various pirate
Crews eventually becoming sir crocodile
second in commands she made it her goal
to seek out all the pony glyphs and
learn the true history of the world
completing and carrying on the will and
work of her friends Pedro a Jaguar mink
who accompanied Luffy to whole cake
Island was once the captain of the Knox
Pirates this group of minks made it
their goal to search for those same Pony
glyphs however on a mission to Big mom's
territory many years ago he and his
comrade zeppo who is Beppo's brother
were captured zeppel was killed but big
mom spared Pedro after he tore out his
own eyes in exchange for her sparing a
few years his life he did so because he
wanted to be alive to see the dawn of
the world use this kit a supernova and
Achieve rival to Luffy was born on a
lawless island in the South Blue
interestingly his backstory was given to
us almost entirely through an SBS
section of the manga volume so not in
the story directly on this island there
were four gang leaders two of whom were
a kid and killer despite being rival
gang leaders the two were great friends
and also had a crush on the very same
girl Victoria however when a criminal
organization killed Victoria kit and
killer United The Gangs of the island to
take revenge their Alliance would
eventually become the kid pirates ending
with them setting sail and entering the
grand line during the Timescape kit as
well as his allies Hawkins in the pool
even challenged red hair Shanks which
resulted in kids losing an arm so that
makes two one-armed red hair characters
in the series facing off again Trafalgar
law a fellow Supernova and chief rival
of Luffy and kit is the sole survivor of
an island in the North Blue called
flavins now flea once was known as the
White City due to its industry of mining
Ember lit however what no one told these
people was that exposure to the
substance had horrible consequences the
terrible amberlet disease plagued the
people of leavens and the world
government murdered everyone who lived
there as a way to prevent the spread of
the disease and what makes it even more
tragic is that the disease wasn't even
contagious law only survived by hiding
within a pile of dead bodies that was
being carted out of the city now after
his escape from fleevin's law joined the
donkey held Pirates surprisingly law
wasn't the only kid hanging around
doflamingo though he befriended
five and buffalo now we don't know much
about Buffalo's past but baby 5 had her
own sad backstory she was abandoned by
her mother who saw her as useless it's
probable that she's called Baby five
because she was literally her mother's
fifth baby her mom didn't even care
enough to give her an actual real name
just a number and so to this day she's
obsessed with serving others and clings
to anyone who shows her the smallest bit
of affection and kindness like many
things in one piece it's played off as a
joke but it's an actual really
unsettling and heartbreaking thing when
you really think about it however law
had one person in his life that he was
much closer to than the other kids in
his age he befriended doflamingo's
brother rosinante or Corazon who was a
secret Marine plotting against his
brother's rise to power knowing that
lost amberlet disease could be cured by
a devil fruit called the opeopenomi
doflamingo made plans to steal the fruit
however doflamingo secretly wanted lots
to eat the fruit so that he could use
its immortality surgery power to
grantoflamingo eternal life and so
Corazon made a plan to steal the fruit
for law first and then succeeded with
that but at the cost of his own life law
narrowly avoided being recaptured by the
doflamingo Pirates and eventually met
Beppo shatshi and penguin starting the
heart pirates with the goal of
eventually taking down doflamingo
Cavendish the captain of the beautiful
Pirates was an up-and-coming superstar
in the pirate World however after the
worst generation made their debuts or
Luffy law kid and Co stole the spotlight
causing Cavendish to hold a really bad
Grudge funny then that he did end up in
Luffy's Grand Fleet Cavendish is also
also possessed by a demon or a curse
called hakuba that takes over his body
whenever he falls asleep still no
explanation at all on how he ended up
with this Affliction but we can guess
that it has something to do with his
cursed sword durantai and bartolomeo was
another Colosseum Contender who unlike
Cavendish wants nothing more than be
working under Luffy ever since he saw
Luffy's failed execution in loketown at
the hands of buggy bargelo Mayo has been
the number one straw hat superfan as
head of the Bardo Club he's collected
every single bouncy poster and followed
every piece of the news throughout
Luffy's Journey forming an entire pirate
crew out of Luffy's Straw Hat fans he
just competed in the Colosseum in order
to win the flame flame fruit back for
Luffy and ended up meeting his Idol in
the process moving on to someone
completely different Duvall the head of
the rosie life Riders he was born into
terrible circumstances namely his face
looked exactly like the Marines terrible
Sanji drawing on his wanted poster being
mistaken for Sanji led to Duval living
alive on the run and constantly wearing
a helmet to hide his true identity
thankfully Sanji kicked his face into a
new handsome shape causing him to turn
his life around completely forgot that
that entire thing happened
jewelry Bonnie is another one of the
Supernova who according to this
childhood drawing has always had a very
healthy appetite bunny is also the
princess of the sorbet Kingdom since she
is Kuma's daughter and there is clearly
a lot more coming for her as well a
sensabo Luffy's adoptive Brothers both
grew up in the Goa Kingdom but under
very different circumstances Ace was
born as the son of pirate king Goldie
Roger but to protect A's Garb raised him
as his own grandson and hit his true
Heritage Saba however was the son of a
noble who longed for Freedom outside of
the niceties of upper class life and
just one thing in sabo's life was even
worse to deal with than the unbearable
customs of nobility his adopted brother
steli who would eventually become the
ruler of the Goa Kingdom and who has one
of the most punchable faces in all of
One Piece Ace and Sabo along with their
younger brother Luffy adventured in the
jungles of their home Island and dreamed
of setting sail as pirates together but
everything changed when a Celestial
Dragon was scheduled to visit the
kingdom you see the Goa Kingdom has many
places in one piece is home to an
enormous class divide the poor people of
this Society were forced to live in a
massive junkyard known as the gray
terminal and lived of the scraps of the
Nobles and so in order to avoid the
Celestial Dragon seeing these
impoverished people the Nobles conspired
to burn the gray terminal and all of the
people in it to the grounds Sabo
actually escaped Goa and set sail with
the goal of becoming a pirate but his
makeshift vessel was shot down by the
celestial dragons arriving and he was
mortally wounded thankfully Monkey D
dragon and his revolutionaries happened
to find the unconscious Sabo not knowing
that Saba was the brother of his
biological son Luffy Dragon raised him
and Sabo eventually became the second in
command of the Revolutionary Army Ace on
the other hand grew up to become a
famous pirate in his own right becoming
whitebeard's fourth division commander
in fact whitebird believed that Ace
would become the king of the Pirates one
day unfortunately after Blackbeard
killed one of the fellow division
commanders in order to steal the
darkness fruit Ace set off in Pursuit
which would eventually result in his
defeat and capture The Swordsman of the
strawhead crew grew up in shimulsky
village and is descended from the
samurai that fled wano country after
orochi's takeover as a kid he trained
hard to overtake his rival kuina at
swordsmanship however after her death at
a young age he swore that he would
achieve their dream of becoming the
world's strongest swordsman Sanji
actually gets not one but two
backstories for the price of one
originally as a prince of the German
Kingdom he was a result of
experimentation by his father wind smoke
judge his siblings who had been deprived
of their emotions tormented him
mercilessly finally after he was freed
from the cruelty of the wind smokes he
found himself in the East blue and while
in the East blue he was working on a
ship as a cook he was endlessly teased
for his dream of finding the all-blue a
sea that brought together fish from all
parts of the world a chef's dream the
ship was then attacked by Pirates but
when a terrible storm nearly drowned
Sanji the pirate Captain Zev saved him
Jeff saved Sanji because he'd overheard
his dream and because he also believed
in the all blue after the Shipwrecked
the pair were deserted on a small island
zeph separated all the food they had
into two portions and divided the island
in half so that each of them could serve
as a lookout in the opposite direction
soon sanji's rations were completely
depleted and he began to starve when he
noticed that Seth's Food Bag was still
nearly full he attempted to steal the
old man's food only to realize that the
bag was full of treasure not fruit Zev
had given Sanji all of the food and had
only survived by eating his own leg
finally the two were rescued and they
founded the baratier the floating
restaurant Nami and her sister nojiko
were both found as babies by a marine
named belmare they grew up peacefully in
their Village but everything changed
when arlong decided to make it the base
of his operations arlong and his
underlings hachan Chu and kurobi had
left the sun Pirates to form their own
crew arlong believed in Fishman's
Supremacy over humans and built arlang
Park as his own Twisted parallel to Saba
ODI Park a place where he and his fellow
fishmen were never allowed to enter as
children arlong made the citizens of
kokoyashi Village pay for their lives
however belmare could only afford to pay
for namis and nojiko's lives and the two
children saw our lungs shoot their
adoptive mother to death in front of
them seeing nami's gift for navigation
and map making arlung held her Village
for ransom saying that he would release
the people there if she worked for him
and bought the village back for 100
million berries unfortunately he had no
intention of ever keeping his end of the
bargain usop from surf Village is the
son of yasop one of shanks's crew
members when he was young his mother
died of an illness usop would make a
habit of lying to the villagers warning
that pirates were coming mainly in the
hope that one day his father truly would
return with his gift for storytelling he
befriended Kaya a wealthy girl in the
village one day he dreamed of becoming a
brave Warrior of the sea like his father
and once he joined Luffy he finally had
the chance to make his dream reality now
we already learned a bunch about Luffy's
backstory when we discussed Ace and Sabo
but let's talk about how Luffy got his
devil fruit and his dream of becoming a
great pirate we met Luffy as a young boy
in fuchsia Village he loved hanging out
at the local bar with his hero a pirate
called red-haired Shanks he always beg
changed to let him join his crew but he
was never allowed since he was just a
little kid one day Luffy took a bite of
a small devil fruit called the govu
gomonomi that Shanks had stolen from a
government ship and doing so apparently
at least gave him rubber Powers later
when a mountain Bandit threatened
Luffy's life Shanks got serious he even
sacrificed his own arm to save Luffy
from a CK Changs once again voyaged away
but gave Luffy his Straw Hat asking him
to return it to him one day once he had
become a gray pirate this hat has become
Luffy's treasure so many of the traits
that Shanks embodied are qualities that
Luffy takes on in the main story on the
other hand Chopper the youngest straw
hat is a blue-nosed reindeer who gained
human intelligence because of that the
other reign reindeer thought of him as a
freak meanwhile the humans of drum
Kingdom mostly saw him as a monster
however Chopper was then treated with
kindness by Dr hirolok a quack doctor
from the island in the coming years
Chopper studied medicine under hero look
developing the goal of one day curing
every disease in the world however
things turned for the words in drum
Island when Walpole took power finally
he monopolized drum Kingdom's medical
expertise by taking the 20 best doctors
for himself and banishing or executing
the rest at this time Hiro look was
facing a terminal disease Chopper tried
to cure him using a poisonous mushroom
that he mistakenly thought was a
medicine however to not have Chopper
feel responsible for his death he took
his own life by drinking one of his
failed concoctions after giving a speech
to Walpole and his men Chapa meanwhile
continued his studies under Dr quresha
until the day that he finally met the
straw hat Pirates the reason why a
reindeer like Chopper was able to gain
human-like intelligence was because he
ate the human human devil fruit in fact
many of the characters that we've
explained so far have devil fruit
abilities as well and since you actually
watched a whole video about every single
bag story in one piece you will
definitely enjoy this video where I
explain every single devil fruit ability
in one piece as well thanks for watching